palabras de aliento para el pueblo
ucraniano y más presión para rusia así
comenzó el discurso del estado de la
unión el presidente joe biden en el que
entre otras cosas anunció el cierre del
espacio aéreo para las aeronaves rusas
en sintonía con sus aliados europeos
voy a anunciar que nos uniremos con esos
aliados al cerrar el espacio aéreo a
todas las aeronaves rusas aislando mucho
más a rusia maiden destacó que el
presidente ruso vladimir putin rechazó
los esfuerzos diplomáticos para evitar
una confrontación y compartimos con el
mundo con anticipación lo que sabíamos
que putin estaba planeando
el último ataque de putin sobre ucrania
fue premeditado y totalmente no
provocado el rechazo reiterada de los
esfuerzos de información desde que
comenzó la invasión eeuu y sus aliados
han presionado el gobierno ruso a través
de sanciones económicas las cuales se
extenderán según lo anunciado por bailén
esta noche le digo a los oligarcas rusos
ya los líderes corruptos que ya no más
a pesar del envío de tropas hayden
indicó que los soldados estadounidenses
no pelearán en territorio ucraniano con
una condición
pero quiero ser claro nuestras fuerzas
no van a entrar en conflicto con fuerzas
rusas en ucrania nuestras fuerzas no van
a ir a europa a combatir en ucrania sino
defender a sus aliados se notan en el
evento el que putin decida seguir
moviéndose hacia el occidente
y mobile west bay le enseña lo que
dispondrá de ayudas por un valor de mil
millones de dólares para el pueblo
ucraniano al tiempo que liberará unos 30
millones de barriles de petróleo para
evitar un alza en los precios del
combustible